that's right
and dressing with your eyes peel off
that spandex
stop that's not what i'm doing these
shores are so tight you can see that his
little dude is also wearing a tiny bank
helmet
okay you seem upset well my business is
in the toilet
i don't have insurance oh i can barely
pay my bills oh
come on today my car got repossessed
other than that
i'm amazing
it's time for you to come face to face
with who you are
and what you're capable of what is this
place the answer to all
your problems
are you kidding me this is a shelter a
safe haven for women to come
without societal judgment come on sam
mclaughlin what you got lizzo
you're up next rocky
[Applause]
are you gonna tough out when to step out
me
guessing i lost her yeah but at least
you fought you took a lot of courage it
would take a miracle worker to help me i
think i know just the guy
that's who you want to train me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i want you to train me train you to do
what ride a bike i'm part of a fight
club that sounds dangerous i am sick and
tired of my demons getting better at me
and i want to
punch them square in the face
i like you heidi anna okay let's go with
that
you don't even hit like a girl you hit
like a cat like a cat that can't box
oh
a place like that should be about real
competition with real fighters
she moves like neo in the matrix i'm not
afraid of you cobra kai
better watch your back yeah well you
better watch your
front parts this pretty face
gonna lose it she's been holding back
i'll see you in here tomorrow night
heads up
let's go
walk away mom jeans these are tight
[Music]
this is
a
crazy
[Laughter]
you